hulk hogan The Ultimate Warrior neon  colors Papa Shango making the ultimate  warrior vomit on Saturday morning  television it was awesome the cold hard  reality is is like there's millions of  guys that think they can be pro  wrestlers and I mean that's that's a  business to choose people up and spits  them out I want to get better I  constantly want to learn and grow as a  wrestler and that's just who I am and  the people that aren't successful are  the ones that don't have discipline what  is your ultimate dream  I don't know mania and then talk shows  and what university think you're  actually gonna be a professional  wrestler in this universe the Milky Way  universe  switch  switch bad  stupid to make a five-year plan really  if you know you're gonna excel in  certain areas so we just kind of don't  plan at all  you